[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
well as I like to call it oh boy
so bad already what where did the well
come from well or as I like to think of
it dear Catherine and Hank it's a comedy
podcast where two brothers and
occasionally instead two married people
answer your questions give you do we use
advice and forgive all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon today
we're joined by my wife Catherine green
because my brother John Green is still
feeling real bad my way my wife yeah hey
it's me Catherine green I'm back again
you step in when John Green comes up
short through no fault of his own oh
yeah third time I don't know I think it
is I don't have memories yeah the time
before I was now yeah you are you have a
child so in the moment and also in the
future
yeah the past is nothing to you
remember nothing just just whatever we
took photos of yeah and saved photos of
thank goodness oh yeah it's been a we've
been I've been collecting all of the
pictures Hank's been on an Elliot quest
our life they're on hard drives they're
on phones they're on different people's
computers they're on old computers and
new computers and Picasa and Yahoo
images Flickr is what I mean and they're
on Google photos and they're on iPhoto
and they're there a Dropbox they're
everywhere and I'm getting all into one
place and it has been weeks
yeah weeks even I mean it's been like
every spare moment - yeah or not there
are not many of but like yeah
Catherine's like what are you doing and
I'm like just uploading another
directory who knew it was gonna be this
difficult I mean I took a lot of
pictures in our life yeah it's been it's
been over a decade since the digital
camera things
yeah and and it's very clear in my
little archives when I got my first
digital camera it was it's very
obviously 2002 2003 when suddenly it's
like Oh went from like having a hundred
pictures a year to having like ten
thousand not ten thousand but a lot and
over 30 thousand pictures I have
uploaded who and now and when I finish
it's your job to decide which ones we
keep and get rid of I'm so looking
forward to deleting I like getting rid
of things it is one of my the chief joys
of my life so yeah my Christmas present
yeah it's like I got these fifty
thousand photographs delete whichever
ones you want the life-changing magic of
tidying up my google photos this is a
good present for a Katherine yeah I
figured out what I want for Christmas
oh thank god I know I hate you you are
the worst
so I've like dropped you several hints I
know some are way more drop me ha what
you want oh yeah oh no some are way more
possible than others but um I don't have
any idea what hint you dropped I guess
there was that one yesterday that was
that a hint or was that just you showing
me an Instagram that you liked she's
making a face I don't know I don't I
think that was just me showing you an
Instagram but you know you can always I
don't know yeah that's a good way to
start so so here's my hand wait you're
gonna hint to me what present you want
alright I carry around in my pockets two
different things huh and I want it to be
one oh all right however however you can
solve that problem it's challenging when
you like change phones when you have
when you have a new phone every three
months about my fault it was it I have
had the same phone for two and a half
years I got a new one it died in two
months I don't know what happened
to it I dropped it and then six hours
later it was like you know what I won't
do anymore anything I'm done with all
things I will exist I am now it's like
yeah right if if a phone isn't a phone
yet a phone no that phone just had an
existential crisis and it gave up it did
suicide I guess yeah and I was really
loving it too so I feel as if I cannot
endorse that phone anymore because it
just stopped working well it's a good
thing that Google sent you this other
one yeah yeah so I I am in the fortunate
position of having Google's occasionally
send me a Google pixel because they're
like hey we want you to enjoy this phone
which I do very much except for when it
just turned on anymore and I don't know
what to do yeah I probably can like I
finally found the little barcode so I
can take it to the Verizon store and be
like this broke and I couldn't find that
barcode and they won't do anything if
you don't have it but I have it now now
I just have to find time to go to the
Verizon store which is like the worst
place ya know if you work at the Verizon
store I'm sure lots of people do but the
Verizon store there are a number of them
in Missoula but mostly there's this one
there was like a sign ordinance this is
it
oh wow we are going off on a tangent so
there's all there's a sign ordinance
here we come this road alone and it says
like your sign can't be bigger than X
you know this this wide and this tall
this aspect ratio welcome to the
fascinating content you have signed up
for and so instead of making a bigger
sign they turned the entire Verizon
store into a sign basically the whole
film like the whole facade of the
million it's like a black building with
red neon around everything and I just
it's so gauche and like it's a nice part
of town it's where I like to McDonald's
is yeah yeah like it but still I'd every
time I Drive by and it used to be this
cute little grocery store yeah well it
wasn't a cute little grocery store it
was a disgusting little grocery it was
it had been a cute little grocery store
for many many many years yeah possibly
decades it was like a yeah it was a
horrifying kind of corner right that was
overgrown and you know it was like half
someone's
and half someone's cheese Mart yeah no
it's a terrible Verizon store so
progress yeah enough is enough enough is
enough
welcome to welcome to 2017 enough is
enough
no matter what side of you are Iran
that's what that's what everybody feels
like this is do bad because we've all
had enough of each other's enough oh boy
and what's more enough for everyone
there really is all yeah yeah there's no
what were we talking about
no phones we did we haven't even gotten
to so how you doing this was how I'm
doing okay I was gonna tell you about my
photos my photo system and I am very I'm
very excited to get done with Apple how
are you doing and also do you want me to
get you anything for Christmas oh my god
Wow what is I don't I don't know if what
wait what are you what was the hints I
can't believe I missed the hints Oh
whose it travel because you've hinted it
some travel but so have I cuz I would
like to go away cuz it gets awful here
in the winter yeah I mean the place I
want to go is maybe not well I don't
know there's there's a variety of ways
this could happen but um I'd like to go
see they might be giants mm-hmm and
they're not coming through here but they
are going on like a tour of everywhere
they're touring again this year um so
that was that was on my list mm-hmm
um however we can make that happen and
you know that's the major one yeah um
hey also how am i doing I just got a
massage for the first time in like two
and a half months so that was okay Merry
Christmas
yeah Merry Christmas me I set it up for
me and you yes I got one too and my baby
yeah my baby we got a little baby
massage for the baby
we're doing this morning the life that
we Leah's live our baby gets a massage I
don't know um I did find a short poem oh
did you yeah it's for you it's by
William Wordsworth perhaps you have
heard of him
mm-hmm I like I was last name has the
word words in it right yeah worse mmm
like words are worse
yeah something better oh man I don't
know I don't know anything about William
Wordsworth except that he's a poet of a
certain era possibly romantic 1770 was
when he was born and then he died in
1772 no I made that up
Wow that's prolific little two-year-old
oh yeah I know I knew I was gonna make
you sad I knew I was gonna make you sad
when as soon as I made that joke I was
like oh why did I do that
okay are you thinking about maybe
William Wordsworth dying yeah baby -
year-old William Wordsworth dying anyway
shall I get to it yeah are you while you
look up who William Wordsworth well it
seems that it's this his actual last
name so at least that that's all you
wanted to know it's okay it's called it
I believe the title of it is to a child
no I don't know small service is true
service while it lasts
of humblest friends bright creature
scored not one the Daisy by the shadow
that it casts protects the lingering
dewdrop from the Sun mm-hmm it was good
and short something happens when people
start saying poetry it turns my mind off
it's like the words hit buttons like the
reset button in my brain that style is
particularly challenging yeah you have
to spend time looking at it yeah so you
know come back to it or don't whatever
it's fine yeah that was my poem for the
day should we answer some questions Hank
this is an advice podcast about death
that's a fantastic idea it's been like
ten minutes this first question comes
from Arthur who asks dear Hank and John
what am I supposed to do with the cereal
crumbs and bits that are left at the end
of the bag box of cereal I like that
it's a bag box because there is a bag in
the box and also you can just be a bag I
can't pour them in with
to the cereal that will ruin the cereal
and the milk not water
yeah not water John's not here
experience by making everything way too
sweet or adding weird texture I can't
throw them away because that's wasteful
and this stuff is expensive what did my
mom do with those bits when I was a kid
could that mean that's a nice job but I
do have a suggestion it was what she
just just knob him while you weren't
around she's like oh my god I'm so
hungry here's a minute pouring them
right down her throat probably the only
I could be only only times she ever has
to eat it's like whenever there's food
nearby
yeah just pour the cereal dust into my
mouth to sustain me for another hour
yeah call your mom and tell her you love
her I'm specifically talking about
Quaker Oatmeal squares the king of
cereals but your answer they are very
good your answer may have slightly more
universal applications please help me
please help bring peace to my mind there
are enough things to worry about at six
o'clock in the morning yeah first of all
don't worry about this also there are
too many things to worry about
we have to stop worrying about yeah I
mean can I not have opinion on this what
do you I mean I can tell you what I do
with them I pour them into the milk and
I eat it yeah oh this this bowl of
cereal was different than the rest of my
bowls of cereal right you know you just
treat it you just treat it as like a
different experience these are left
there is the challenge of like can i
separate these from the and without meal
squares you kind of can because you can
like pull out the things that are whole
mm-hmm
finish that then put the the dust in
right and then it's like porridge
instead are you CRA Orange well in the
thing like for frosted mini-wheats then
you really they get really sweet cuz
it's all the sugar bits that fell off
that is that is some sugary milk I just
made open those squares are different
because they're not they're consistent
throughout to make an oatmeal square
porridge so I have suggestions if you
don't want to just trash them or put
them down your InSinkErator granola I
don't know I'm sorry the texture is
already weird in there uh-huh
squirrel food squirrel food yeah yeah
yeah
you like birds or squirrels maybe
they'll eat it just encourage the
rodents and things to come to your house
no it's like Cinderella maybe they'll be
friends and make you a dress later yeah
do you know the difference between
porridge and gruel I do yes because we
were talking about it the other day
yes but I probably would have been able
to tell you the difference earlier than
that
apparently gruel is drinkable yes like a
liquid it's like a thin liquid yeah
soup sounds bad now that it's not well
yeah you know it's not the king of
cereals is certainly not and also it is
called gruel which made it like bad
branding decision yeah who came up with
that one interesting like that the word
for it is so unappetizing cruel it's
growing oh yeah I feel I kind of feel
the same way about all all of the the
hot wets of the cereal kingdom like
oatmeal like I get us have not yet been
able to get behind oatmeal and I'm 37
years old this is I feel like I'm
getting into the stage of my life where
I should be more of an oatmeal kind of
person but I just can't get there but I
am now to the point where I can have
like muesli and yogurt like I can do
that and I'm happy not warm no but like
yeah as soon as it's warm I'm like out
warm cereals I'm out the door
maybe I need another ten years and then
I'll be a warm cereal guy I feel like it
is something that happens to people as
they get older my dad's always eaten
warm cereal is he no he does the same
thing you do he's granola and yogurt
maybe maybe its genetic I remember I
remember a lot of oatmeal happening well
anyway should we move on this is an
interesting discussion about what
breakfast foods you like let's answer
another question dear Hank and John I am
currently working as an assistant
English teacher in Japan the experience
is great but as I don't speak Japanese
very well my way of making friends
usually consists of looking interested
while people talk at me and nodding my
head and making a Hanoi cz's recently
though this method has as I found
later resulted in one of the art
teachers at my school offering to do a
portrait of me to give to my mom and you
agreed to this well you know not in your
ha I'm all I'm of course flattered but
also slightly afraid I don't usually
like renditions of myself that okay yeah
but even more worryingly I especially
don't want to give a portrait of myself
as a gift to anyone no matter the
quality and then there's that old saying
that has been running through my mind of
how the fastest way to lose a friend is
to paint them wow that's not a saying
I've ever heard no any and all
questionable advice will be greatly
appreciated see you later ADA oh yeah I
wait so the fastest way to lose a friend
is to paint them that would not result
in me losing a friend because everyone
would be like of course that looks
terrible I think has painted one thing
Hank ler fish and only one is a fish
that's all you start and then it's like
yeah and then it's like it's you have
eyes right glasses yeah stripy shirt cuz
you wear stripy shirt yeah what's your
distinguishing feature I couldn't tell
you a single thing in your hair with a
ponytail right yeah an oarfish with a
ponytail
anyway ada I think you got you well I
mean you feel like you gotta sit for a
portrait this sounds cool just take this
as like an interesting experience you're
gonna have whether or not you give it to
your mom is your decision once they give
it to you yeah so your mother would love
a portrait I knew that would that might
be really nice you're in Japan where's
your mom she's not with you all the time
she wants to see your face yeah
especially painted by a Japanese art I
know that sounds like such a cool
present it sounds like a pretty cool
present and if your mom doesn't want to
maybe to send it to me send him to Hank
I'm John Green no well it's okay you
can't take a cell phone picture of it
though and send it to Hank and John at
gmail.com we would like to see a tree on
it that's if you're interested in
sharing the portrait that comes out of
this yes we would like to put it on the
patreon for others to see do you feel
like if someone asks to paint you that
there's more coming along with that
request than just I would like to paint
you like is it is it a tight
panic situation I don't know there's so
many ways this could go I don't know if
she doesn't say anything
concern in that department because I
would the art teacher is or what her
relationship with this person is others
like that like is this person flirting
with you and you're just not sure cuz
you know language and cultural barriers
yeah I don't know I feel like if I think
I mean you know if you don't feel
comfortable with it oh yeah don't
obviously don't do it but like if it
just seems like an innocent I'm this
person is interested in making a facial
study yeah like because you probably I
don't know may don't look like the
person that the people that this this
art teacher sees all the time yeah so
maybe they just want a different a
different face to look at um I don't I
don't I think you know obviously up to
you but if it was me I'd do it yeah yeah
the end the end
this next question comes from Brooke who
asks dear Hank and John it is winter
which means that it is cold so cold that
I am reminded of that scene in Star Wars
where Luke is walking in the frozen
tundra and then he cuts open the inside
of an animal and just like gets in to
keep warm how cold does it have to be
where this is okay Brook babbling brook
cuz it is kind of babbling yeah oh you
gonna gag her girl oh gosh I doubt God
had a lot of thoughts about opening up a
tauntaun how do go cold doesn't have to
be for it to be okay to cut open it well
first of all I think the tauntaun died
if the tauntaun had already died of
exhaustion yeah which seems unlikely to
me like right how is Luke Luke would die
first yeah this was like pre Jedi like
strengthening aren't lightsaber is hot
I can't you just like huddle up with
your lightsaber if you have a lightsaber
doesn't that couldn't that keep you warm
couldn't you like just cut just like
getting like warm your hands on it I
don't know I don't know I've never -
I've never know physics of lightsaber I
don't get when they are fictional I know
that when they touch people the people
get burned
yeah I think that they'd hot yeah do you
think
hot sometimes it cauterizes the wound
and sometimes the people bleed I think
it's interesting that like Star Wars
lightsaber wounds often don't bleed
because there's so little blood in Star
Wars and that sort of like one of the
ways that they're sort of more kid
content that there isn't as much
bleeding and like lightsabers and
blasters don't tend to leave blood
except for some reason in the cantina on
mas in the mice Eisley spaceport when
they cut off that guy's arm it bleeds
and the first one but that was like
early on
yeah maybe was just a different body
type
yeah alien physiology yeah mmm huh
anyway how cold does it have to be where
this is okay uh I mean I think that if
it's life or death
I don't know it's up to you but I'd kill
an animal to live and that includes
crawling into the bowels of a beast of
burden this is the thing you know you
just never know you get in these
situations right what sort of you know
nasty things you will find yourself to
be capable or I'm gonna find out about
yourself yeah though those mmm yep
that's why you just don't put yourself
in that situation that's right yeah I
don't need to you don't need to be out
there in the cold where that is okay
yeah we we have gotten to this point in
human yeah cultural evolution where that
is not necessary yeah like don't go
helicoptering to the top of a mountain
oh yeah and like get left there by
yourself so yeah necessary good for you
and it's not good for the Bison that
you're ultimately gonna cut open and
things like that no I mean like also are
there wildlife up there no cuz they'd
they freakin no they left you're out
they're not up there they know that's
not a place for peeps to be don't be up
there peeps
so yeah too cold for you is how cold too
cold too cold don't go to places where
it's too cold and it won't be a problem
also warm yourself on your lightsabre if
it comes to that yeah I do not do do not
do right this question comes from
Twitter thank you for sending
your Twitter question dear Hank and
Katherine my future wife and I want to
build a tiny house for ourselves is this
a good idea or just a load of crap I am
a man in a cup Joe doesn't Sarah like
get your name specific sign off but
maybe somebody else will sure I I do I
do feel like people come down on one of
those two sides like tiny houses are a
point of opinion inflection where people
are either like I get it and I want to
live inside of a place where when I sit
up I hit my head on the roof versus
people who are like oh my god I get over
this weird and so I mean I think the
motivation is good it's like simplifying
your life I don't need all this
extraneous thing building one yeah I
could see being interesting just because
you're like how do I get all the things
that normally are in a normal sized
house mm-hmm into a tiny house um and
also you get to learn about plumbing and
electricity and carpentry and all those
things like without having to build a
whole house right and ruining a whole
house or yeah ruining without without
ruining a whole house or a whole houses
worth of lumber totally it's like a
practice house yeah just practice on
this one and then if it's just take it
to the dump
sorry about the S word yeah it's already
on a trailer then scrape it off no no
you should instruct it and you know
reuse the lumber and whatever yeah um I
is it I mean I think it is limited
viability your people some people can
totally do it and cool whatever that's
that's that's fine for them some people
live in the woods what yeah I mean the
thing that has always seemed a little
weird to me is like if you want to live
in a tiny space they exist their
apartments and their trailers and
they're like mobile homes like there's
lots of tiny
but like there's something about the
tiny house that is like appealing it's
you
it's our aesthetic yeah in my mind that
is not actually doesn't actually
correspond with how I would like to live
yeah it's just um that I like to look at
and think about rather than something
that I would like to be a part of and
actually have it be part of my life like
I like to have like an imaginary space
you know where you can like it's sort of
like this like magical TARDIS place yeah
and it is I'm like I love looking at
them and like dwell or whatever
sure yeah house hunters but you know I'm
aware that this is not actually a
lifestyle that I would enjoy living yeah
and I I think it's try it out first
before you go through the whole thing of
like buying one and building it and
whatever I bet you can VRBO a tiny house
yeah yeah
and also there's challenges like legally
logistically and things like you got to
find a place to put it
yeah it's like yeah there's already
houses on all the normal house places
and what is your motivation like why why
do you want to do this like do you want
to limit your consumption what what I
think you should investigate your
motivations for for this impulse um and
also how tiny is tiny I have a friend
actually just building a tiny house
apartment community so six tiny houses
they don't share walls but they're not
that tiny they're 500 square feet which
is how big my first apartment was
whereas a lot of tiny houses like a
hundred square feet 150 square feet
which is just like ridiculous literally
like flatbed trailer yep by truck size
yeah and whereas this is like yeah it's
a 500 square foot apartment like that's
a way that lots of people live yeah or
like fitting a tiny house into a
shipping container has always been very
appealing to me like ah this this house
fits in a shipping container how neat
but I've gone to visit some of those and
I'm like how does this work and they're
like it's actually pretty expensive
because shipping containers aren't cheap
they're made of steel like they're
extremely made of steel going through
all the thing of like retrofitting that
it's not easy because it's not done a
lot and so I you know anything that's
done more than once
is easier yeah you know that's why we do
we do these conveyor belt things mm-hmm
style things but right answer no I I'm I
can I not have an opinion on this
oh you yeah and I don't either like you
can do whatever you want but this
question but hopefully we're helping
people develop develop an opinion our
next question comes from les who asks
dear Hank and Katherine what happens if
I have a kid and it doesn't like dog
what do I do about the kid Oh what if it
doesn't like dog first of all is your
dog's name dog yeah or is it just or it
was a typo probably a typo but I like it
better in a world where it's just dog
what a way if I have a kid and it
doesn't like dog just like a panic like
it's just and I understand like yeah if
it doesn't like dog what if it doesn't
like dog here's here's a tip I have my
nephew was very very allergic to animals
when he was first born and he loved dog
and cat and bird and all an animal but
he was really really allergic to them so
they just had to wait and you know
eventually he kind of grew out of the
allergies but you know there's there's
time in your life to learn to love dog
yeah and also if they don't you know
every person is a different person
that's right and you can't force your
child to be anything right here's that
it does not want to be tell you from
what having watched a lot of people who
had dogs and then had kids is that the
dog becomes less important to you oh yes
I mean you still love this dog yeah but
you are it is not top of the pack
anymore yeah and maybe you don't love it
all that much for a while
maybe for a while that's like how on
earth am I supposed to take care of this
and why are you still can you take care
of yourself you're a fully grown animal
yeah I need to stop being off the carpet
right some people are totally capable of
like expanding their hearts to film to
to
and anything but some people aren't and
that's fine too you know you can only do
as much as you want but once you have a
baby that's the priority
you gotta recognize that but yeah if you
have a kid who doesn't like dogs though
you can keep dog like the yes you could
have things in your house that your kid
doesn't like I have a ton of them
oh yeah well no he seems to like every
doesn't really like he doesn't like
sometimes it doesn't like getting his
butt wiped right now he doesn't yeah it
doesn't like the washcloth that we wipe
his face well yes he doesn't like face
wiping that's not like a thing probably
like the thing in his house that he he
is most like has both positive and
negative feelings toward like the large
like the thing that he has the largest
negatives feelings toward he's us oh
yeah totally cuz we're always trying to
make him do stuff you write everything
like most things he's either yes or he
loves them she loves he like loves and
also hates I wouldn't say hate but yeah
tolerates with I mean sometimes he's
pretty upset I'm like dude I just have
to do all the bedtime stuff yes it
through the bed I know your butt hurts
stuff you say bad diaper rash this week
got a wipe is it looks so much better
today everything's gonna be fine guys
our baby's butt is good um here's a
question from Michael dear brothers of
Clan green or wife and husband of Clan
green I like to walk around on campus
when it is dark I enjoy it because it is
peaceful and not many people are out and
about I not really walk faster than most
so when there's another person I would
normally walk past them but I don't want
to freak them out by making it feel like
I am approaching them but but if I slow
down and we're going in the same general
direction it seems like I'm following
them what do I do
paavo mediocracy salvat a you know I
looked that up Michael and I don't sorry
about my Latin I do not do Latin up and
Google also can't handle this because
Google said it meant peacock regarding
goodbye good so I don't know what it
actually means
Michael meant to say peacock regarding
goodbye um I don't know that's all I got
for you in terms of the sign-off in
terms of the question right here's what
you do
just turn just like I'm gonna walk
across the what the Gleaves now yeah
right if your head dude if you're just
taking a walk you can go any direction
you want right yeah I do this all the
time where I'm like I feel awkward this
person knows I'm here but doesn't want
to turn around to look at me it's gotta
go into the woods but it's not that's
not creepy at all the bush hide other
solution right you can go with yours but
I have another solution wait what is
what I said just turn yeah yeah first
solution yeah I have another solution
okay rollerblades ah all right I mean
there's nothing less threatening like
you cannot be like oh here comes a guy
on rollerblades better get out my mace I
don't know but the thing is on
rollerblades people know that you're not
approaching they're like people know
that you're gonna be passing them
because you have wheels you got the
racket feet and there is something
really non-threatening about a guy on
rollerblades especially if they're like
like hockey skates or like not like if
they're like trick skates maybe you like
that guy looks a little bit cool yeah
like and if he might he might but like
if you're like doing got skates that are
just for likes you got them Fitness
skates on Fitness skates Fitness skates
nothing sexier which is the only kind of
oh man I love rollerblading I know it's
just not possible here in the Montana we
got we got bad weather and bad sidewalks
yeah because of the bad weather yeah
yeah so I I have nicely people around
try doing it but I'm like that's got a
beat just yeah got a nightmare oh man I
think we can't be now that one out of
the park I
but like yes this is like a legit fear
that I have that I'm freaking people out
by walking up behind them
yeah but cuz I might call them big guy
right yeah totally yes yeah I don't
necessarily feel this I mean I maybe I
have felt the other way where I'm like
what's that person behind you I yeah I
really doing but generally I just don't
care about it and I just wanted to say
that Michael said that his girlfriend
Jenna's a huge fan and we should say hi
hi Jen
how are you hi Jen I'm Hanks wife
you don't really probably care about me
I'm sorry I'm a substance surrogate John
this next question comes from Hannah who
asks dear Hank and John the other day I
was having a conversation with my friend
and she started telling me something
that I had originally told her she
stated beforehand that she had heard it
from someone but didn't remember who so
it's not like she was like stealing my
anecdote anecdotal facts but I was not
sure how I should proceed I ended up
just sitting there and listening to it
as if hearing it for the first time but
like was i lying and also wasting
everyone's time apricots and alley cats
Hannah yes you were lying and also
wasting everyone's time and you did the
right thing
yeah I guess I do that like when John
does this to me
I'm always like yeah you told me that
before or like yeah I told you that yeah
I guess it wouldn't it would depend like
how close you are with this person yeah
whether you would want to be like yeah I
totally told you that why what yeah yeah
or well or if you just want to be like
in the interest of just getting through
your life right minimal conflict like
what there was that moment when she was
like this is something that I heard but
I don't remember who I heard it from
right yeah this thing you'd be like oh
that was me
weird right cool yeah cuz then you can
have that conversation instead of you
just sitting there being like you did
this doctor
I told you about this yeah I know all
about the Ship of Theseus oh my god so
just next time so this next time you're
you can you can you can break in and say
yeah I'm the one that told you that I'm
the source of all your best facts I mean
Hank green what will steal all your
stories I will steal them back to you
like you never existed in the first
place
he's he's he's a story amoeba I don't
think you'd do it intentionally but we
definitely don't do it intentional but
you do but you do absorb absorb stories
into your mom's John does it - oh yeah
yeah so I think it's I think it's pretty
natural you're like I have a great story
I told this I yeah just you just want to
be an interesting you're always calling
me out on my BS oh it's not mean it's
minimal BS you know but here's a here's
a um there's a better question oh not
that that was a bad question
it's from Adam and the subject of the
email was the mysterious ticking noise
mmm Adam says dear Hank and John or
Catherine when I stay over at my
friend's house always sleep on the couch
there happens to be a clock very nearby
that ticks very loudly the ticking is so
disruptive that it renders me unable to
sleep while slowly chipping away at my
soul what do I do it's not a bridge it's
a damn batteries I'll take them
batteries out I mean if it has batteries
does it come off the wall is it like a
is it mobile take it somewhere else yeah
put it right I mean I mean unless it's
like a grandfather clock Oh like when
have I ever told you the story here's
another question like why you sleepin on
the couch in your friend's house
what do you mean right now sleep on the
floor in your friend's room that's
lesbiana captain the 400 head
uh-uh what they call what they call them
earplugs yeah there you go you just you
just bring earplugs to your friend's
house every time or you just leave a
pair there you put them on that clock
cuz then you'll know where they are or
like hide them inside the clock
somewhere so that everybody who sleeps
on the couch and they're like there's
earplugs in the clock these are the
clock earplugs
umm yeah or like a deer muffs or
something you know that I'd like when
I'm on tour sometimes I end up sleeping
in rooms with ya guys who snore right
and noises you cannot avoid yeah and and
if you turn it like get a nap like a
white noise app the one I use is called
simply noise and you put your earbuds in
your phone and then in your ear and you
play white noise directly in your ear
you will not hear it if the world ends
right into your brain it just call it
just turns you right off and I do this
it's a fairly regular this is a good
this is a good trick and it's good for
everyone everyone should do it you need
to sleep you need to sleep it's amazing
to me the way that some people are able
to sleep because I have had such a
pampered life did I ever tell you the
story of the time that I had my computer
in the guest bedroom of my house and I
created a screen saver for that computer
in which us I wouldn't ID not like there
was a picture of me this was the
screensaver that I made and I knocked on
the screen from the inside and it made a
knocking noise though of like we're
knocking on glass and there was a whole
bunch of news story to me I am a little
freaked out there's a whole bunch more
to the screensaver but that was part of
it and it was about a two-minute loop
and my John's girlfriend came to visit
and slept in the guest bedroom and we
turned off the computer monitor but the
speaker's were still on so every two
minutes the computer made a noise like
someone knocking on the inside of the
computer glass well as the CRT much like
a I can hear it yeah yeah yeah yeah and
so and and like terrible
all like she did not sleep but she was
in that room all night long with that
noise happening every two minutes and I
was just like you have to get up and
just pull the plug out of the wall
embrace to speak like you there's a
number and like if this is bothering you
it's totally fine as long as you like
set the clock back in the morning or you
put it in the bathroom and you like oh
the collecting was bothering me I took
care of it
I am a a person who is more important
than the location of a clock yes it's
fine it's fine to be like can I move
this while you sleep here tonight or
yeah whatever
but if you don't want to do that yeah
earplugs yeah or your button or your
white noise and simply noise
yes bond so sponsor this podcast podcast
sponsored by simply noise the app that
is free and has all kinds of different
noises it has white noise it has brown
noise bad news noise it doesn't work on
my phone and because they it does not
work on newer versions of iOS oh yeah so
some sort of white noise app maybe I
know is is gonna by simply noise so that
we can continue to update the software
because I imagine they don't make a ton
of money off of hair like I just it
literally is just there's nothing else
it was no frills it was beautiful right
I just had like them do you think you
could yep the noise and you could pick
the volume yep um a lot of these other
ones they got all kinds of choices and
things on them and I don't care about
that like Night Lights
anyway this podcast is also brought to
you by a bag box of cereal minimum maker
oatmeal squares the king of cereals oh
good this podcast is brought to you by
fitness blades fitness rollerblades you
can go fast without ever looking even a
little bit threatening come on up and
put on these fitness blades you will not
get a date
that's true you'll only get dates from
really really cool people okay
this podcast is also brought to you by a
lightsaber maybe uh it can keep you warm
[Laughter]
if you're looking for a tool like that
it's a great tool yeah that cert could
serve you some purpose especially like
if you have like a tiny house that you
need to take apart because it turned out
that was a bad idea exactly perfect
you need to deconstruct that tiny house
real fast lightsaber it up
and this podcast is additionally brought
to you by our actual sponsor which is
merchandise for dear Hank and John we've
got new merchandise I didn't know that
he's literally brought the t-shirt into
the studio as though I could show it to
you all we could see it I mean I can see
it can you hear it
we got literally holding it up so I can
describe okay so the words dear Hank and
John are on the shirt it's a black shirt
very nice black shirt inside of an
octagon shape like a stop sign mm-hmm
and all of those things are made out of
one guess omegas they are yeah or
possibly amazing
or possibly amazing yeah dear Hank and
John first new product it's beautiful
its primary colors plus green mm-hm and
the shirt is black and I mean if you
like this podcast Hank what that was me
tearing off the taggers it's got a tear
tax you have to be with the tag yeah
that's great and then you then you never
know how to wash it again um I just
watched it teach it treat it like a
t-shirt t-shirt one give it a t-shirt
wash yeah wash it on American cheese is
that the end of the regular normal yeah
are there any other questions we need to
answer or should we just uh a couple
we've also got a sticker we've got a
sticker to get put that on somethin and
we have a poster as well as secret
snakes poster oh there is one more
question I need okay - all right
this question comes from Maggie who asks
dear Hank and Katherine how did cave
people cut their fingernails did they
even cut them Oh No or did they just
break all the time
God cringing over prehistoric keratin
Maggie agreed Maggie thank you for
making me think about this and now I am
giving it to the rest of the pod
listeners now all of you have to think
about this as well just I mean there's
nothing better to think about than just
your like your fingernails breaking all
the time I have no idea and I did not
research this and I wonder if anyone has
thought about it yes but probably yeah
so I did a little bit of research okay
great it comes through yeah so other for
like like as far as what prehistoric
people did we've got some guesses but we
know a hundred percent what chimpanzees
do sure sure sure sure
they chew their fingernails chimpanzees
chew their own fingernails that was my
first thought yeah was that they just
trimmed him off with their own yeah
teeth and it says that's a enter anymore
other animals do this too like cats will
chew off their tonot toenails when they
get too long well they they they chew up
those teeth
all right right yeah and so we found
nearest part of the normal grooming
fates from like the like the Roman times
and Egyptian times kuzey
yeah nail care kits from the Romans and
apparently like there was a person that
you went to like the same person who
would trim your beard in your hair okay
the dentist yeah who probably also a
dentist did you make that - yes I feel
like the dentist was also like the
person that shaved you right a certain
point in time probably yes just like
this is the guy who took care of all the
weird things on your body parts if like
you can good yeah uh Cairo I don't know
that's coming up trying to come up with
a Greek name and I said Cairo nope
that's not that's not gonna do it for
you bar just destroy Oh Oh a name of the
mayor of approach this right Auggie well
that's more of a Roman name is not dang
it wow he's really failing over there
looking good Xerxes no that was the
Persian guy what are some Greek people
good George Stephanopoulos oh sure
that's a last name I was thinking about
you know like Aristotle looking good so
crates there you go you got there that
was good well thanks for looking that up
for me now I don't have to worry about
it you know like I also don't really
think about like thinking about right
I'll dust you and fingernails you and
some but when people there are like when
you do work like manual labor like like
like manual agriculture yeah nails do
break a lot and it you don't probably
have to chew your fingernails because
you're digging in the dirt and you're
just carrying heavy things all the time
and yeah oh yeah yep we're both like
yeah both like twiddling our fingernails
at the moment anyway
the way that they are ranked as should
we get to
the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon we
sure show that time for that great as
the guest of the pod I have the pleasure
bringing you the news from AFC Wimbledon
and this is hot off the presses from
yesterday November 21st which is going
to be not so new for the rest of you
when you hear this next week sound more
exciting Wimbledon continued their
upturn in fortunes with the desperately
hard-fought goalless draw at Oldham are
you reading yes I'm reading that I'm
reading the BBC calm sport article
because they have done the work for me
the Dons had their backs to the wall for
almost the entire 90 minutes yes they
give you the the shots line up there and
it's 16 shots from Oldham to Wimbledon's
2 so they really were up against the
wall but a determined rearguard action
saw them deny their inform hosts thank
goodness for the rear guard because
nil-nil drawers seems like the best that
Wimbledon can hope for at the moment
[Music]
Nile Taylor fired over for Wimbledon
before home striker craig davies found
the net with a rebound only to be ruled
offside I know
and then Oldham seized control but a
brilliant last-ditch tackle by Wimbledon
captain Barry fuller kept the scoresheet
blank so they're hanging in there I
think there's still like one slot out of
relegation there at 19th right now yeah
and they have to be in the top 20 well
so hang on there with the little
fingernails that they probably trim with
some clippers or something instead of
their teeth for who knows maybe when it
feels as tight as it is right now they
may be they are chewing them hmm
well so that's the news from America's
favorite
third - your English football team the
the Mars news is also mixed so you heard
a couple years ago that there were these
recurring dark stripes that would flow
seemingly flow down like steep areas for
Mars and it was liquid water on Mars may
not be liquid water on Mars is the new
paper that is out so the the main
argument that this paper makes is that
these stripes appear at like just at the
places and at this the slope angle that
and mostly on sand dunes where sand is
continuously replenished that the sand
would fall at and it stops they stopped
when the slope angle gets to the place
where sand would not fall anymore and so
they think it's some sort of might just
be like a dark sand thing but the
original thought behind it being water
was twofold one there were some of like
some of these salts that would
significantly lower the freezing point
of water so that the water would stay
liquid for longer okay in colder areas
so the salts were there which made sense
that then the water would be sort of
this liquid slushy stuff and also they
were seasonal so it would only happen in
the summertime when it was warmer so
there'd be liquid sort of seeping out
was the idea when it got warmer some
stuff was melting and the liquid was
seeping out the liquid water was seeping
out right but the sort of counter
arguments there are that those salts are
around so maybe this isn't this
situation and and it did it just
happened to be in those places and then
as far as the seasonality there is also
some seasonality to how dust moves
around on Mars so that could be not
water and there's really no way to tell
with the current instruments that we
have orbiting Mars at a point
those instruments and likes be able to
tell just by like looking at it what it
is
we'd have to either have new instruments
that would do something I don't know how
they would do it if you could do
spectroscopy from that far away and have
it detect water or you got to go right
up onto it and be like hey what's up
yeah
and they probably NASA really doesn't to
do that because they're worried that
curiosity has like earth microbes on it
that they could potentially contaminate
any ground in that area is probably
quite unstable 30-degree slopes seems
dangerous to send your Rover there yep
good point so maybe maybe is the 2020
Rover gonna have any like probes that
can launch from it you know that would
be interesting there has been a thought
about that about having basically a
quadcopter like a dragon that would go
off of it but they would mostly be using
that to scout so to see okay like higher
resolution where the rover is gonna go
rather than planning yeah science on its
own
well maybe you can think about having a
science drone instead higher or in
addition but these are cells what they
always doing on the enterprise they're
like send a probe and I can't get the
enterprise near it it's too dangerous
sorry nobody else got to see that face
that was my serious starship captain
face and voice yeah but these are
they're called recurring slope lineae
and there are a ton of them now when we
found them all over the place which is
all sort of another reason why we're
like maybe this isn't water because
they're everywhere they found hundreds
of them right like hundreds of different
locations not just hundreds of slopes so
that's that that's the sort of womp-womp
of the day it might just be just yeah I
mean you know seems likely to me there
is a cold dead planet there is to be
clear plenty of water on Mars just not
liquid water people get very confused by
this like
but definitely lots of water on Mars we
see that all over the place
yeah we just have the different word for
it we call it Isis yes well I guess when
you say we who do you mean because I
would human all ice water humans no
scientists refer to all states of water
as water okay but there but there are
different words for water when it is in
different states
yes well water water vapour humans use
yeah we call it steam sometimes yeah I
guess we call it steam yeah I mean it's
not like when you say ice you're talking
about like a that's the thing that
alcohol thing yeah but no one normally
is doing that like if I just have like a
block of iron no that's kind of like ice
fire nice yeah cuz it's not like that's
totally how like normal human beings
talk and think just say ice but like
there are other ices I know
but especially on other planets are you
doing science communication for lay
people I'm just saying for the most part
right yes so I see we should just say
ice water right there's lots of ice yeah
there's lots of ice on Mars water ice
there's also lots of dry ice on Mars and
we have a word for that as well it's
called dry ice
mmm water ice
now I'm confused it's a BB wheel those
are not related accent I know but okay
what are you confused about no no never
mind it's not important a dry ice and
water ice right well dry ice is carbon
dioxide ice oh okay thank you yeah yes
that's what I needed
okay Katherine yes thank you for potting
with me what did we learn today wait we
got to the end already it happened why
did we learn today I don't remember I
told you about this in the beginning we
learned that like there's that cereal
dust at the bottom of the of the bag
and you don't know what happened to it
when your kid growing up because your
mom was just out there like taking care
of business because she was so hungry I
just had the thought of like you know
like dip like dipping like the dip sugar
oh good lord like fun day fun dip yeah
like doing that like just like licking a
popsicle stick and a mom like rolling it
around in the frosting and that frosted
mini-wheats you know I probably want to
eat some [ __ ] probably like poured it
into her like cold cold cup of coffee
and was like this will do everybody
thank your mom yeah we also learned that
if kid doesn't like dog then you could
keep kid and dog and that's to be okay
not everybody in the house left to like
each other yeah I mean this is a good
lesson for your kid Yeah right yes
nothing things aren't always perfect and
I'll tell you what cat does not like
baby with that poor cat yep sorry cat oh
we also learned that you know the
Verizon will get around any sort of sign
ordinance by just making their building
a sign taking over the creepy little
grocery store when they sold stinky
cheese corporate espionage that's not
the right word no whatever but we also
learned that lightsabers are extremely
effective at deconstructing your tiny
house once you've decided to move past
that lifestyle I mean I mean I yeah nope
whatever great lighthouses that was this
way
Legos are kind of tiny houses that has
got really big lights on them yeah well
yes lighthouses are a house for a light
and a light is both tiny and infinite
[Laughter]
hey Catherine do you want to go make
this weekend Ryan's with me patreon I
sure do if you want to get access to
this week is Ryan's you need to come on
over and join us on the dear
dear Hank and John patreon for $5.00 a
month mm-hmm you can get access to this
quality bonus content I paid for it and
I probably didn't have to but I yeah I
pay for it I don't really know what the
money goes to from the dear Hank and
John patreon what everything okay yeah
just it's just funding helping to fund
complexly enterprises so yeah you know
you can feel good about it it's not like
John and Hank are like give me them
fives i'ma roll around in all nope it
funds like scishow and crash for some
stuff yeah so yeah come on over come on
over the patreon join us it's this week
in Ryan's yeah I'm not gonna do it no my
let Hank do that yeah so we're gonna do
that but in the meantime thank you for
listening thank you to Nick Jenkins our
editor our this podcast is produced by
rosianna halse rojas and Sheridan Gibson
our head of community and communications
is Victoria bon giorno my guest host
today has been Katherine green the
wonderful music you're hearing right now
is by the great gunnarolla and as they
say in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]